all right hundreds of you have emailed
me about my cameo in a Netflix
documentary that at one point over the
weekend was the number one show in the
United States about The Disappearance of
Malaysian Airlines flight 370 and most
of you said to me David they're making
you look like a conspiracy theorist
based on the clip and of you and how
they're using it and yes they are now
I'm going to explain to you what's going
on I am admitting up front
what happened here is my fault I could
have prevented this from happening and
I'm going to explain why but here's the
big picture
insanely popular Netflix docu-series
called MH370 the plane that disappeared
I'm briefly in it and the clip of me is
actually of me debunking a conspiracy
theory but the way the show is edited it
makes it look like I am one of many
people spreading a conspiracy theory
about this very flight so let me tell
you the origins of this back in March of
I got an email from raw TV and a
producer there who said hi I work for
raw TV who are currently producing a
documentary about missing Malaysian
Airlines flight mh370. I'm potentially
interested in featuring a clip from your
YouTube video Below in our documentary
is this something you might be
interested in and it is the clip is
called debunked
debunked Flight MH370 Rothschild patent
conspiracy theory this is from Glenn
okay so uh I in general I in general let
people use the content with attribution
for projects this is just like a general
thing that I do usually they don't offer
any money because they're really low
budget but in this particular case they
did offer money because they have a
bigger budget so Glenn wrote back and
said thanks for getting back to me I'd
be licensing a short clip for use within
the documentary covering the following
rights worldwide all media in perpetuity
it's not exclusive so you can continue
to do whatever you want with the video I
can offer an end credit and a license
fee of 500 US dollars if the clip makes
the final cut so I said sounds good 500
bucks when I usually would get zero and
say use it as long as you credit me that
sounds absolutely fine the problem is
that in the documentary they include me
in a context that makes it seem as
though I am perpetuating The Conspiracy
Theory here is the clip take a look take
a listen
saw the damage plane covered in Black
and black another conspiracy an
outrageous Insurance scan some of these
people showed up outside my office who
would chase me down in a car park it was
quite scary I remember screening an
ankle once trying to escape one of these
people who really just wanted to bring
their Theory to me four days after the
flight disappeared there was a patent
issued for a new semiconductor
technology others Wonder did it land on
the U.S military base so they include me
in this list of conspiracy theories and
then they show a guy looking at it and
then the guy clicks share the idea being
that I was part of the spread of
conspiracy theories
the reality of course is the entire
video was debunking that very conspiracy
theory this would be sort of like if I
said one of the most disgusting things
that neo-nazis say is Jews or blah blah
blah and then you just cut out where I
quote the Neo-Nazi and you include me in
a montage where I say Jews do blah blah
blah and then I'm now part of the of the
Neo-Nazi conspiracy theory or whatever
the case may be now
ultimately this is my fault and I'll
explain why yes they knew they were
being dishonest the title says debunked
and they make it seem like I am bunking
rather than debunking but I should have
requested something in the license that
said
a lawyer emailed me about this I should
have requested something that in the
licensing agreement
I tailored the specific use I don't
rather than giving a general license I
should have said the context must be one
that makes clear that I am debunking
rather than spreading and that I don't
believe this conspiracy theory I am
quoting
I didn't do that now I lived and I
learned they paid the 500 bucks they got
their license and now it's one of the
biggest shows on Netflix and it makes me
look like a conspiracy theory theorist
so I certainly learned a lesson that
being said
another lawyer reached out and said
David
it's fine that you're blaming yourself I
mentioned this on yesterday's stream
it's fine that you're blaming yourself
for not getting a more specific license
but the truth is
they still deliberately and maliciously
misedited that in order to make it seem
like you're saying the opposite of what
you're seeing you actually could sue
them
should I sue is the question I don't
know sounds like it could be an
interesting story so maybe I should but
I'm not super inclined to do that I will
follow up with this
um if I have the opportunity if there's
anything to tell you